that we've been expected to come down to
stuff down here there's many uses I have
been doing
but it seemed like it's open like you
just do what you want to do when I first
got here it was like man I enjoy doing I
do in hindsight it's like I came down
here it was like an open part everywhere
you go
they're getting high in the streets I
walked beside the buildings at the parks
and seemed like the police would just
roll by and it didn't really bother them
thank you so I got so like I arrived
like I'm home now just get high like I
want to
I forgot about what life is about
became part of it you know what they
call DTG man it's like
I've been to a whole lot of seen a whole
lot then stabbed four times out here in
this piece seeing people have been
thrown out the windows of buildings
we also adapted to the Vipers like our
gravitates like magnetic to me is like
wherever I do decide to go leaving try
to stay away I it's hard
you gotta mess I mean beautiful people I
met a lot of beautiful people the only
changes just don't know how like myself
I go to program and stay in the program
and I won't stay because they don't seem
like that's where I want to be because
it's nobody there that I already know I
played sports I had played a lot of
sports and I was good at sports
nice ball was really one of my number
one sports I played a pretty good well I
had a had a scholarship to go to New
Mexico play football I was a quarterback
at Blair high school in Pasadena and
soon as I graduated high school I was
already in the game banging hanging out
and end up getting a direct sale to the
police and they gave me eight years and
that's my scholarship father and this is
my penis like I didn't see fit to try to
do anything else that
I have any other benefit besides selling
drugs you know but only other activities
that we do with the street being shot
you know
we're 12 geisha girl in Louisville
common for 76 days this was right when I
was like 16 years old I've gangbanged
healthy
and I walked in the store and it was
raining then my coat was real wet
because I had been out there all night
already so that's what kind of saved my
life because they didn't penetrate all
the way do and leave me right here in my
side right here close to my chest I
still have buckshot soon
see my brothers and sisters my siblings
and stuff our you know they was always
in that lifestyle and by me being the
youngest I liked it what they was doing
and I wanted to be a part of my mom
pulling me over here telling me I need
to stay in school and I need to write I
did graduated high school I wouldn't do
that afterwards
I like to do walk the streets in May on
streets more
I've been shot seven different times in
my life
stabbed three times hit by a bus hit by
Volkswagen made by dog thrown in the
trash can
and Steve here man
you just had a birthday I'm 52 yeah I
having kids
and the wrong meaning don't with one
young lady only know she had baby nice
she said she was pregnant she got out of
town I don't know where she I don't know
she kept the baby she had him baby
if she was pregnant she told me she's
pregnant you know I have a I have 76
nieces and nephews that's pretty huge I
don't even know happen
uh missing one just my mom my dad came
around everybody actually all my
brothers and sisters who lived there and
then big house with my mom residence
doing everything she could my dad came
in and out I'm gonna didn't have too
much of a relationship with him trying
to guilt up animosity towards me because
he would beat my mom up all the time he
come around he saw I really didn't too
much like the scene when he shove it up
my mom she was uh almost like a
caregiver she just cared about everybody
a lot of my sister's all my brothers and
sisters graduating high school cover my
brothers went to the service I was more
like the prodigal son the only one of
the product concern I just was like that
knucklehead ended up in the streets and
first time I ever got shot was when I
was 12 years old and I was hanging out
in the park doing a couple of friends
and I guess I wanted to be a tough guy
iboga I want to try to protect everybody
else and I was like man I was suit too
you know and I was like I don't care and
you did what number 222 be shopping in
my hand because I put my hand out but
and I thought I was exempt after that
like yes how about no honey didn't
really matter
my mom always been a Christian lady
trying to raise up raise her up to be
spiritual to get to know who God is and
I had a brother that we stay on me my
older brother and that was one of the
reason why I was played a lot of sports
concede it was more like a dad he stayed
around with me and hung out with me and
helped me you know with my homework at
school and stuff you know and that was
one of my strongest points is staying
active with playing sports I love sports
I would play in the summertime play
maybe some some leagues Pop Warner
football
and I know it was hard for my mom to pay
for a lot of stuff because he had 12
weeks and at the time they they you know
they were partly lifestyle you know him
Singh you know what they call hookers I
don't like to call women that but my
family my sisters and brothers was a
part of that lifestyle right there and I
thought that was the life to live
because they had a lot of money in low
rider cars and nice clothes and my mom
was trying to get me to see it the other
said other way but I couldn't see it the
other way because I was seeing this here
visually in my face and I end up selling
drugs and that's how I ended up going to
the pen for eight years and I went to
possible penitentiary right after high
school
eighteen
yeah I was supportive tossing around
krill yeah I was real active meaning
like dealing really wasn't a whole lot
of shooting back in the 80s and stuff
it's like white really shoot too much
but then that stuff started happening -
I see
yes really yes I'm here
I took the whole is his tycoons
a childhood whatever clear back in
inside
you know hoping is it
they were still talking to me to
excitement
so holy splash
I don't carry enough this is like me I
was my icing party in junior high high
school play sports together
and always saw myself I'd only be that
close to the various images to use my
that closer hurts but meaning of heaven
no no it's a process for two
this pathway just like me
so I stay down here and I came down here
and I got to do this downtown LA and I
came down here man how'd he come down
here to stay over I came down here and I
was shopping I was in a relationship
when young lady that worked for 20 hours
she was here she had twins and I can
either go shopping and I ended up
downtown I met this young lady and I was
getting out at the time we go to the
hotel up dere see some hotel to hang out
and stuff and she told me she'll be
right back and she left the door cracked
and there's some guys down we got to be
down here came in here Robbie and I
don't have any more money at home so I
ended up staying down here or you know
robbing somebody else and when I did
that I found what I was hanging out that
didn't hi ad and I'd upstanding and I
walked around for two weeks just saying
close them didn't care about taking a
shower didn't care about ten clothes
people standing there get away from me
around my feet was hurting
and sores on
and I became a product of downtown and
almost every street you can think about
and got high on and then I've seen some
stuff so much stuff happening downtown
that I never thought I'd see my life
from the things that could make you
smile from the deans that'll make you
fire I never thought I'd see something
let's go on mind a little bitty small
city and the city has so much clout like
this is this is a money city where
someone's going
I've been down here for so long I hadn't
got on Gio for like the first 10 years I
never got on just hustling industry
you know
then it was time to work I would stay up
so long like two three four days my body
is so tired but I want to go lay down to
where I would fall on my face and I
would literally try to stay up and I
couldn't in my body would just give up
and give out on me and I fall flat on my
face in another street or sidewalk and
bless my face okay no blast my head then
still don't want to go to hospital then
we just stay there
not me dealing with my pay me in this
you know I'm gonna get sober at times in
this talk about them sometimes I don't
care but majority times I do their
cleaning at one time like four years and
I was only because I had got locked up
and they sent me to a program and I'll
counter
it's called Quincy's place I was
uncomfortable avoid I and I was going to
meet his out there and I met someone and
she was real nice
she was nervous she's beautiful and so
she would always say just don't go just
don't go downtown in the whole time I
was sober I like to think about is my
mother gonna show them how I look
and we didn't see how I'm looking at and
after like three and a half years clean
having some stuff going it going to
college I was El Camino College you know
I picked up the degree in uh children
services I was uh got some education and
I was good like three and a half years
and I came downtown in the new quarter
soon and without his doing and after
Amanda half-hour Becky night
[Music]
yes that's all I smoke crack cocaine
I'll try how can you say I even try
other drugs black smoked it just for the
taste and see the effect did you I I try
charming I want to never ever try
anything
Wow excuse me
that scared me you know some amount of
fluids and TCP if they call sure and I
tried that in and it's already it's bad
enough that it stinks so much smells bad
and the speed crystal I don't even
understand what is too high it what's
the rush
I don't even understand the feeling of
that huh they call it go fast I mean
I've seen people however stay up
I see somebody stay up to 21 days
that's some days
my last smoke was crack cocaine
and I know I've asked me crack cocaine
before anywhere for like I was going to
a heart attack I was about to have a
heart attack
well like I was going to go in to see
the county made me want to stop but
didn't did craving craving be so intense
and the monkey on your back so heavily
to where it won't it won't let you go
just too much this a month and a half
ago you know right outside this my
outside right here on a sentence down to
Spanish guys rolled up on me on bikes
two in the morning but her knees don't
even get to see your face one ride on
this side and one riding on this side
and they're coming the same way that I'm
going and I look to my right to see this
guy with school he was gonna do and this
guy stabbed me in my stomach he just
recently he's dead now Helen just a
month ago
I was in ICU for six weeks canoes
bathroom can be couldn't defecate the
worst pain I read you stabbed me and
they say [ __ ] PT negro
I mean [ __ ] [ __ ] I thought it was
like a joke and I went to try to run
catch up with him and I took like two
steps in I was out of breath I bled for
a long time right here on this corner I
record on the corner of the light I
walked in that corner and I sat down and
I was bleeding all over the place and
guy wrote up on Vikings like men's
smooth what's up man I was like 19 hours
if you go down here to the fire station
fire department emmalin's came to pick
me up but he came to checked on me and
called the up man
and I was a USC Medical for six weeks
Rhoda can breathe I was an IV I was a
breathing machine no no no
[Music]
this one home did we test move
that's why now I'm a living testimony I
don't know what God's plans are for me I
know got to be some good but I study
going on the way down sometimes and
still today the guys can walk by me and
I wouldn't even know who was never even
done that doing I'm not even a racist
person I'm gonna buy his person
absolutely
I never wake up in the morning but no
money in my pocket
I understand it better not be home not
knowing if I'm gonna get something I
know where I'm gonna be something that
don't even having a cup of water
anyway cups already off the ground just
sleeping on the sidewalk and the body
already sore from the ground causing so
much pain in your back and your body so
you starting off with getting up off the
feet off the ground
and whatever little stuff that you had
been around you it's already gone and
took it now I've been rambling through
so you're gentle with that and you'd
have been on some of the same blocks
already that you don't already ask the
same people to help you out so you don't
want to keep burning your bridges on
that so now you're thinking of a plan
like man I'm gonna go to a store or
something
welcome out of stores just get something
to eat without any money are you hungry
then I'm done there now going around so
Target or something I start opening it
up food and walking around like I'm
shopping but I'm eating kill them all
[Music]
so I can get through today I'm going in
the bathroom in there and just wash my
face wash up clean up a little bit so
that no one noticed that I you know
slept outside didn't hoping that the day
will change throughout that hoping that
somewhere someway that somehow my father
left to get some money because now I ate
and had something drinking I didn't
washed up a little bit now I'm one guy
so now you know flattening how I'm gonna
give my next high and I coming with
title coming with that plan so I would
stay walking around my feet start her
you know sit down and I'm already tired
I'll eat something and I'll fall asleep
right where I'm at
unintentionally but my body would be so
tired to where I would fall asleep then
wake up with stuff going sometimes I
wake up my stuff still there
[Laughter]
I'm sorry everybody gonna get that
chance to where you're gonna do so much
it's like your turn your turn I mean I
don't had days made work all the whole
day was real bad there was no look at me
with nothing just see my man life is
over downtown
you really meet the heart of a person
down
real Jason
find out the good the bad indifferent
right you can see
[Music]